J clap again no hi i'm saba rooney Lurie
I'm a licensed Marriage and Family
Therapist and a board-certified art
therapist I'm the owner and founder of
take root therapy a group psychotherapy
practice in Los Angeles California today
I'm going to be reviewing some couples
and romantic comedies no don't pull that
with me don't even try it this is not
how you treat your friend what I saw in
that segment was how difficult it can be
gonna be in a relationship with someone
when you're starting off oftentimes our
attachment stuff will come up so we may
think we really want a relationship and
when it shows up it can be really
overwhelming I like you Tom I just don't
want to what you're not the only one who
gets a say in this and often times to we
are really clear about what we don't
want
and yet we might engage in behaviors or
in a relationship that is outside of
that realm so I imagine most of us can
really connect with that feeling of but
you're showing me something different it
was confusing to me to hear her say I
don't want a relationship and then have
her show up at this guy's door so if I
had to guess at this relationship within
the last I would suspect that it's not
just because it seems like they're both
on different pages
at the go but if one person is saying I
don't want a relationship and one person
is saying but we're in one it can be
really difficult to move forward from
that I'm sorry
imagine your husband bought a gold
necklace and come Christmas gave it some
day
we all want to think that when we're in
a relationship that if we agree to be in
a monogamous exclusive relationship
that's why it's going to be and we know
from experience from knowing friends and
family that a lot of impede led does
exist in relationships would you stay
knowing life would always be a little
bit worse would you cut and run when one
has been married for a long time I don't
think that that's necessarily an easy
answer nor is it always the ideal or
appropriate answer so you can see this
woman really struggling with what do I
do now
and she's confronting him with that I'm
sure classic yes be father made a fool
out of me we've made that life I leave
foolish do I think there's a chance for
them I think that she was really candid
and really vulnerable and instead of
defending himself instead of writing her
off or pretending that she's wrong he
looks like he's also acknowledging the
pain that she's feeling and that he's
put her in this situation so I think
that if they're willing to work through
this they can make you see yangshin you
there is the push how co-op went on you
quit know what the sooner come what this
yeah Emma I remember seeing this movie
and having a really strong emotional
reaction during the scene and I can feel
it now this frustration this anger with
Nick's family and their expectations of
him and their attempts to really derail
his relationship I hired a private
investigator mom she look into her past
do you have any idea the scandal this
would have cost for Rachel to hide
something like this as someone hits a
first-generation American there's a lot
of impact of having a family from a
different culture and what they want for
you and what they expect and what you
may want for yourself but that's not an
easy choice to make and I think here you
can see that he's actually leaving his
family like he physically has to to run
from them and chase the woman that he's
in love with in terms of prognosis for
their relationship he he seemed to
choose her
and in any relationship that would need
to come first seriously who are these
women
okay um know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture is it those women
these are women in Pakistan who want to
marry you
they're not in Pakistan so I think this
one's interesting
right after crazy rotations because in
both there's this cultural component
there's a cultural expectation and it's
being confronted by this relationship
that doesn't follow standard rules
there's such a liar is there someone
that you're not lying to you
I'd love to meet them because then I
could tell them are you supposed to be
good at having shoes as a therapist do I
really appreciate the part about like oh
yeah we don't have our together and
we're not always good to be calm cool
and collected and that doesn't make this
any less effective as therapists so I
like that piece too you know what we
call arranged marriage in Pakistan Emily
marriage my cousin Rehan made an
Irishwoman and he was kicked out of the
family nobody is allowed to talk to him
having a family that you really care
about and you don't want to disappoint
and and knowing that you might by making
your own choices is a hard one God was
my friend prognosis ooh
medium as a man sir I think that they
would need to work through a lot and to
be asked to sacrifice your family in the
name of love is not an easy choice to
make maybe one is happy but the other
isn't or vice versa just so you know
nothing happened between me and Jen last
night I'm tired of being second best or
fake best I don't know how often we
really experience these things where we
have an agreement we pretend to
something you know then we fall in love
like this is one of those times when I
think Holly wouldn't maybe misses the
mark a little bit about reality but the
idea that we have a hard time trusting
our partners a imagine is pretty common
okay look I leave we just go inside and
talk about this yes you leave buddy wait
this isn't about Jenna and me at all no
this is about you and Josh you're still
in love with this Barney there wanna be
here in left
Josh Morgan no what a tangled web
sometimes in a relationship when we get
started we're not always being a hundred
percent honest and then that might come
back to haunt us later on Peter go home
yeah you were never second best I think
what most of us all of us want in a
relationship is to feel really secure
and connected and like we can trust a
partner prognosis
I think poor and it might be hard to
recover and be really authentic really
honest connected in a relationship
yes I'll order a pizza I'm sorry Harry
I know it's new usually I know you're
feeling lonely but you just can't show
up here tell me you love me and expect
that to make everything all right how
about this way I love that you get cold
when it's 71 degrees oh I love that it
takes you an hour and a half to order a
sandwich I love to get a little crinkle
above your nose when you're looking at
me like I'm nuts I love that after I
spend the day with you I can still smell
your perfume on my clothes and I love
that you are the last person I want to
talk to before I go to sleep at night
and it's not because I'm lonely and it's
not big or just New Year's Eve I came
here tonight because when you realize
you want to spend the rest of your life
with somebody you want the rest of your
life to start as soon as possible
I think what we can take what we can
hope for is that in relationships when
we have friendship that that's really
going to help us be connected I'm like I
was saying earlier to feel like we can
trust that we're secure that somebody
gets us how important is it to feel like
somebody understands you and to have a
relationship that lasts feeling
understood is so important I really hate
you
and also that they can fight and they
can recover we're going to have conflict
with partners it's just a matter of life
but if we can find a way to come back
recover and laugh and kiss yeah that
would be nice
prognosis I want to say you know strong
they have a good strong relationship
ahead of them that's what I think anyway
it's about old friends
[Music]